[Music]
filmmaking now all of slimness is back
to almost old school technology becomes
invisible and that's a great thing
fantasy has no bounds there's no
boundaries and what you can do here with
the new technologies we are I think had
a vision for what bad version of it was
and and what was written in there was
just that it was a little baby of Yoda
species when Dave first read it I know
he did a little drawing on the flight
home and then that went over to Doug
Chiang and Doug started doing some works
on not to the baby but the pram that
egg-shaped pram the reaching in the kind
of Michelangelo Sistine Chapel et
imagery which started to develop at the
same time to look for the baby itself
the look of the big years we had
inherited that from Yoda and I had
already been preoccupied with with the
look of big eyes and and and using ears
promotion was something that I had
wanted to try and we got lots and lots
of drawings some of them were too cute
some of them were too ugly some of them
were the wrong proportions but they were
all informing as we gave notes on each
drawing Dave and I we started zeroing in
on what it was and it finally it was one
image that Chris Osmond did that had him
wrapped up in what looked like a piece
of a flight jacket or something we
didn't know and his eyes were a little
weird he looked a little out of it and
something a little off with it but we
found it charming and that became the
rallying image that we said this is this
is good and it developed from there and
then once we had that then they started
to do maquettes of that but the maquette
wasn't cute and then we started to work
through it and that's when the people
from legacy came in that's really when
it became the baby
[Music]
on the throne left okay it's starting to
take on a life of its own but it had a
little extra spark that just happens
sometimes and I can't always explain it
sometimes it just becomes extra magical
it comes forward tilting head up a
little bit yeah now reach oh my god the
director just writes it like it's just a
single character you know we all just do
the direction but then you take the part
that's specific to what you're operating
with them and you know when the heads
gonna turn left I'll try to beat it with
leading with the eyes and the ears ago
up to give it you know it just starts to
work itself out look at it you don't
even need a story just put the camera on
the baby it wins your heart over he's
not born the culture today so let's take
the time to do that right let's give
ourselves plenty of footage seeing him
on camera and seeing him in person the
way that it activates your your primal
childhood dreams we're all gonna be
second fiddle to this to this little guy
that's how cool he is should I build
some home or he looks gathers himself
and it holds up the two hands forward
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Star Wars the
Mandalorian season 2 video we have a big
baby Yoda clip of them and making the
character a whole bunch of behind the
scenes details and we got a big rundown
of all the episodes so I'll explain all
the episode titles what the references
and the Easter eggs they're going for
and which characters will show up during
which episodes so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there will be a lot more
Mandalorian season to stuff happening in
the next couple of months because the
show is premiering earlier than it did
last year there's that far ahead of
production schedule even though the
virus has shut everything down they've
been going strong on the Mandalorian so
we'll talk about the baby Otis stuff
first then I'll talk about all the
episode titles in the synopsis for each
of the episodes obviously they do a
really good job of showing you how they
use it on set they use the practical
puppet just like they would use the
traditional Yoda puppet during the
original trilogy
since the prequels in the new trilogy
they've done a mixture of puppets in CGI
Yoda like during the new trilogy they
try to go back to using a puppet the
reason why he looks so weird during the
last Jedi is because they were using a
different mold to try and make him look
younger but it just wound up feeling
kind of strange so if you felt like Yoda
was weird during that movie that's why
but you can clearly tell when it came to
doing this series they wanted to go back
to using a puppet just because it works
so much better in scenes but what they
do is is you see them using it on set
here like you can see Dave Filoni sort
of directing it in the puppeteers when
they get to post-production and special
effects they'll tune up his expressions
the way his ears move because it's all
about his eyes and what's going on with
his ears so most of the time he's
communicating with his body language but
the really cool thing about season 2
baby Yoda is that they've said that
they've learned how to use the puppet
that much better in scenes they've
almost perfected it so if you really
like the way they used him in scenes is
gonna be even crazier during season 2
even Giancarlo Esposito who plays mouth
Gideon has been talking about his scenes
during season 2 with baby Yoda about how
he's super fascinated by the dark saber
itself which kind of makes you wonder
what those scenes are like what is going
on the baby oda is in the scene watching
Moff gideon and fight with the dark
saber unless Mothe gideon manages to
track them down halfway through the
season that sounds like a scene from the
finale but just getting into the actual
episode titles in synopsis there are
eight episodes just like there were
during season one and i'm assuming that
the length of the episode
is realtively similar maybe a little bit
longer now that they've kind of figured
out production cycle now these are just
working titles so the actual titles
could change but it gives you an idea
for what's going on because they make
very specific references so episode one
right now has titled the search that's
probably just about Mandalorian and baby
Yoda searching for more Jedi to train
him in the force very simple premise and
obviously while all these episodes are
going on usually episode 2 episode he
takes some sort of bounty to earn money
so that they can pay for ship repairs
episode 2 is title of the confrontation
the title makes it sound kind of like a
mundane fight that they get into but the
season 2 cast list is stacked with
original trilogy characters I've already
been a bunch of season 2 videos about
the new characters that they've
announced the really big ones from the
movies or from the animated series like
the Clone Wars
so the confrontation that they get into
is probably with one of those really big
Easter Egg characters episode 3 is just
titled the bounty so is either a
reference to the bounty that Moff Gideon
takes out on baby Yoda or it's a
reference to a bounty that the
Mandalorian takes to earn more money
episode 4 is just titled the Republic
right now is probably just a Cara Doon
specific episode that gets into her
backstory in history as a republic shock
trooper episode 4 of season 1 was also
kind of her episode of the Mandalorian
as well even though she appeared in
multiple episodes the whole thing about
her during season 2 is that she's
actually agreed to become grief cargas
enforcer so she's mostly gonna be
located on this planet but I wouldn't be
surprised if she winds up flying around
to other planets every once in a while
with the Mandalorian just because
they're spending most of the season
looking for other Jedi doesn't mean that
they won't come back to this planet so
it's not like you're never gonna see
these other characters again they're
obviously still a big part of season 2
episode 5 is just titled the loyalists
right now it's hard to say which
character this is about specifically but
it's probably another big original
trilogy Easter egg the reference is
probably specific to someone who is
loyal or still loyal to the Empire after
its fall so it could be a moth Gideon
episode Giancarlo Esposito implied that
he had way more screentime in episodes
than he did during season 1 because he
really only showed up right there at the
end
here's a big one though episode 6 is
supposedly titled the sorcerer right now
as you probably guess this might wind up
being their ahsoka tano episode because
sorcerers is what the Mandalorian in the
armor referred to the Jedi as
all we really know about ahsoka tano
right now during season two is that
she's gonna be played by rosario Dawson
in supposedly she's signing a contract
to appear in multiple different
live-action Disney Plus series as ahsoka
there's rumors about her appearing
during the ob1 series at some point
there are a bunch of spin-offs of the
Mandalorian that they're developing at
Lucasfilm right now so she could appear
in those because people are also talking
about other characters from rebels like
sabine and ezra bridger coming into the
live-action series there's even rumors
about them developing a spinoff series
just for ahsoka like ahsoka a Star Wars
story but doing it as a Disney Plus
series then episode 7 also sounds like
another big one so the title right now
is just listed as the returned this
could be their big Boba Fett episode we
know he's coming to season two and he's
returning from quote-unquote Return of
the Jedi so the title could be both a
verb as in he's returning to the story
but also a reference to the title of
episode six Return of the Jedi
Tim O'Hara Morrison is playing Boba Fett
because Boba Fett is a clone of Jango
Fett who created all the other clones so
of course it would be him it's just an
older version of him but Timothy
Olyphant
is supposedly going to be the person who
stole Boba Fett's armor from the
aftermath novel and is gonna be a
sheriff of one of the towns on Tatooine
so Boba Fett when he comes back won't
have his signature armor from the
original trilogy there's more Boba Fett
stuff happening during season 3 so I'll
talk about that in a second too after I
talk about the finale right now episode
8 the finale is just titled or at least
working title the Empire this is
probably obviously major Mothe Gideon
baby Yoda episode right now because
they've already renewed the show for
multiple seasons I'm expecting them to
end on a sort of Empire Strikes Back
cliffhanger like a bit of a downer
ending where Mothe Gideon might wind up
being able to take baby Yoda from the
mando Giancarlo Esposito Jon Favreau
Dave Filoni have talked about how they
weave in a lot of Darth Vader Easter
eggs to his character he's sort of a
Darth Vader type character for the
series so he'd be a terrible villain if
he couldn't make good on his threats so
at some point he has to land a big win
and for him that is getting his hands on
baby Yoda right now the biggest news
about season 3 characters is that season
3 is actually supposed to be big for
Boba Fett like he'll be in some of
season 2 but he's gonna have a much
bigger story during season 3 we don't
know exactly what that's going to be
if they're gonna give him some sort of
redemption arc because the whole thing
about the Mandalorians series is it's
about the Mandalorian culture as much as
it is about the character their Creed
Mandalorians aren't a race they're a
creed so it's all about taking the oath
and holding true to their code of honor
and boba fett does not follow their code
of honor he's just a guy that wears
Mandalorian armor so maybe they'll give
him some sort of redemptive arc because
I don't feel like they would do Tim wear
a morrison dirty if they were gonna
bring him back to play these huge
characters but everyone let me know in
the comments what do you want them to do
with Boba Fett during the series if he's
only gonna have a little bit of screen
time during season 2 and have a bigger
story during season 3 what will happen
is is we get any other big news or
casting announcements about big
characters coming from the movies I will
totally do a video about it there should
be some more Mandalorian season two
trailers dropping in the next couple of
months too while you wait for everything
click here for all my Star Wars
Mandalorian season 2 videos and click
here for my brand new Justice League
Snyder cut teaser trailer video thank
you so much for watching everyone stays
safe I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you